c'est tout
[Musique]
ça a été un lancement réussi pour la
nasa qui a envoyé ce matin une nouvelle
sont deux sur la planète mars le rebours
persévérance et va s'y poser quelque
part l'an prochain dont la mission se
sera de trouver des preuves de la
présence de formes de vie sur la planète
rouge ya une ingénieur né au québec qui
sera vraiment aux premières loges de
cette mission-là farahani b est vrai
qu'aux commandes du véhicule qui va se
poser sur la planète rouge à distance
évidemment on va la rejoindre dans le
sud de la californie bonjour madame à
libé bonjour bon alors toutes nos
félicitations pour ce lancement réussi
comment vous l'avez vécu ce matin merci
super excité en fait j'étais à la maison
on a eu un appel de conférences avec
toute l'équipe donc séparément à cause
de la crise mais ensemble via l'internet
et chivu nerveuse et non mais moi je
pense que j'ai j'ai peut-être dormi une
demi-heure d'années passées c'est c'est
mon deuxième lancement va mars mais ça
on s'habitue peu donc c'était vraiment
nerveux ça va beaucoup mieux mais je
commence un petit peu avoir faim à me
réveiller un peu ça fait ça fait
quelques jours que j'avais des noeuds
dans l'estomac mais c'est pas fini là on
est vraiment on est en route fin mars on
a parti on n'est plus dans la gravité de
la terre on est vraiment en route mais
pour les sept prochains mois ça va être
des petites corrections et plein
préparation pour l'atterrissage en
février bon parlez-nous justement du
rôle que vous allez occuper parce que on
vous a présenté comme l'une des
personnes qui allait piloter ce robot là
à distance est ce que c'est à peu près
ça c'est peut-être résumé c'est
grossièrement aussi là donc je fais
partie d'une équipe je fais partie de ce
qui est l'opération de la surface c'est
une grosse équipe on est quand même au
début une centaine de jours en jours on
est une cinquantaine qui qui pilote ce
robot l'assaut mars tant que je suis pas
tout seul bien sûr mais je vais faire
partie de l'équipe qui va faire les
opérations de jour en jour sur mars et
surtout à les 90 premiers jours sont les
jours les plus importants
en fait l'équipe va travailler chaque
jour pendant la nuit martienne environ 2
de 18 heures
de mars jusqu'à 6 heures du matin heure
de mars est en fait qui est intéressant
avec ça c'est que les journées somers
sont de 24 heures et demie donc chaque
jour
oui à chaque jour vous aviez comprise ce
que j'ai à chaque jour notre travail
commence
une demi heure plus tard donc même si on
commence à la même sur mars et un
décalage horaire à chaque jour donc on a
toute une équipe ensemble qui fait
l'opération de ce robot la star sait
comment ça va fonctionner expliquez nous
vous avez quoi des télécommande à
distance
ça ressemble pas un jeu vidéo l'on en
parle mais qu'est ce que vous vous allez
voir un visuel de la planète
exactement à 5,6 fort c'est que mars
parce qu'on est quand même très loin de
la table bien sûr on est là des millions
de kilomètres
on peut pas on peut pas faire comme un
joystick c'est pas comme un jeu vidéo
parce que pour le signal on utilise un
signal de radio pour communiquer avec
cet astre mobile et pour que le signal
se rendent vers mars
ça prend entre 7 et 12 minutes et après
ça pour revenir ça prend notre site
à 12 minutes donc ce serait un jeu vidéo
assez plate sur l'état s'il apparaît
comme à attendre 14 minutes pour que le
signe assez reviennent donc ce qu'on
fait c'est que nous on travaille pendant
que le lasso mobile d'or donc la nuit
sur mars
on reçoit nous quand on rentre au
travail on reçoit toutes les données que
persévérance a pris pendant sa journée à
elle donc il ya des photos il ya des
commandes y avait toutes les données de
toutes les extrêmes en les choses comme
ça on analyse tout ça très rapidement
entre ça ne prend une heure ou deux de
faire l'analyse et après on a une équipe
qui prépare le plan pour la journée
prochaine donc ensemble on prépare un
plan sont oxydés commande qu'on envoie
vers le robot et le matin quand deux
précédents se réveille on envoie sa part
radio on mais c'est vraiment inscrivez
dans la nuit on peut au main à la main
serait malgré six heures du matin on lui
envoie son plan et on était voici va
faire ça toute la journée et le soir on
revient pour pour regarder ce qui s'est
passé mais ça prend quand même la place
de la patience est ce que vous
espérer retrouver sur mars donc le but
persévérance et c'est de trouver des
signes de vie mais bien sûr le plus
important dans ce qu'on va faire c'est
qu'on va prendre des échantillons sur
mars on a la possibilité de prendre plus
qu'une vingtaine d'échantillons et le
bus éventuellement c'est de ramener ces
gens sont friands la veille vers la
terre donc ce maçon à certains
instruments mais ce qui est vraiment
intéressant c'est que si on peut ramener
un morceau de mars sur la terre ça nous
permet de faire beaucoup plus de
beaucoup plus des sciences le répondre à
beaucoup de questions est ce qu'on se
pose à propos de la planète mais comment
vous allez ramener ces échantillons l'a
donc le plan c c'est en développement
mais l'idée d'envoyer un autre un autre
automobile un autre sauveur 20 mars pour
aller chercher ces essences yolain et
après on aurait une petite fusée qui
partiraient 2 mars vers la terre donc ça
serait bataillon il y aurait quelque
chose d'autre en orbite qui se
rencontrer avec la fusée et pour amener
les échantillons vers la terre donc si
vous pensez que le lancement aujourd'hui
été compliqué
j'avais les échantillons de mars et
faire un lancement de mars ça va être
des chose de plus compliqué qu'on va
faire à issia nasa va devoir se faire
dans la réalité et non le science
fiction le robot il est en route
peut-être comme deuxième question qu'est
ce qui va se passer dans les prochains
mois pour vous là j'imagine quand on ne
reste pas les bras croisés à attendre
que leur bosse pause on doit se
l'appliqué on doit s'entraîner
exactement
en fait il ya deux équipes sur la
mission si vraiment il ya l'équipe qui
ce qui qui s'occupe du robot en ce
moment dans son chemin vers mars
donc dans les prochaines semaines on va
faire une correction de notre dans notre
chemin pour vraiment se pointer
exactement vers notre site
d'atterrissage sur mars
donc cette équipe l'oeuvre est occupé à
s'occuper du robot et l'équipe donc moi
je fais partie l'équipe de surface nous
on se prépare exactement pour
l'opération les opérations sur les
surfaces donc on va faire deux choses
on a un groupe akka sable ici au gpl qui
est près de chez moi c'est et
on appelle ça le mendiant en fait c'est
un environnement martiens et on a une
réplique du robot persévérance qu'on
utilise dans ce bac à sable est donc on
va faire une des courses à obstacles en
fait pour l'heure où notre robot on va
le conduire et et apprendre comment le
robot comment le robot fonctionne dans
différents environnements et en plus de
ça on se pratique aussi en tant
qu'équipe
donc pour faire les opérations sur mars
est pas quelque chose qu'on apprend à
l'école c'est pas quelque chose qu'on
peut apprendre ailleurs
donc on se fait des pratiques on se fait
des pratiques comme au théâtre comme on
pratique avant avant une grosse
performance fait nuance pratique avant
d'atterrir aux bars et bien d'écouter
fera à libé comme dirait notre collègue
charles tisseyre c'est fascinant on
aurait poursuivi la discussion avec vous
encore durant de nombreuses minutes on
vous remercie beaucoup parce qu'on 6 une
journée qui est pas mal occupé elle a
commencé très tôt aussi pour vous cette
journée là merci d'avoir été là ce matin
merci et félicitations encore au revoir